germany's domestic intelligence agency
is putting some members of the
anti-lockdown queerdenka protest
movement under surveillance it allows
authorities to collect data on
individuals and groups
who are suspected of spreading
conspiracy theories and misinformation
about the pandemic the
german interior ministry said the
movement had extremist tendencies
it fears it its influence could last
beyond the end
of the pandemic
well for more on this i'm now joined by
our political correspondent ania
shafinat at our parliamentary studios
here in berlin anya
who exactly are the queen because it's a
very very diverse movement isn't it
yeah fair denkin roughly translates as
lateral thinking or thinking against the
grain and this movement was only
founded last year as a direct response
to the corona pandemic and
more specifically the german
government's handling of the corona
pandemic
so they're a very young movement but
they've already created quite a stir
here in germany
and they're at the heart of most of the
big
anti-lockdown demonstrations that we've
seen across the country in recent months
and and like yuri said they're a
disparate bunch really they're not part
of
of one political organization or all
share a political persuasion
they're an eclectic mix of people with
you know legitimate
grievances against government lockdown
measures
but also outright corona deniers general
conspiracy theorists
and then there's also right-wing
extremists and even
neo-nazi groups that that march
alongside them
and in the bundestag the german
parliament they've got uh
support from the biggest opposition
party uh the right-wing populist
afd so why have they
been put under surveillance now it's not
the whole movement that's under
surveillance is it
no there are certain groups amongst the
movement that have been put under
surveillance we don't know exactly which
groups they are
but some german states had already had
already
put um some of the movement under
surveillance that's baden-wurttemberg
for example hamburg and also bavaria
and the bavarian state leader marco zuda
called for them to be put under national
surveillance as early as november last
year and now that has now happened and
and of course you should always sort of
listen up
uh when a government national
intelligence service
puts a group under surveillance who are
protesting against
government measures and but
the the the intelligence service has
stated that
that the that group the clerdenka are
using
what are legitimate demonstrations and
concerns against
um government measures for illegitimate
ends
and and that is to undermine the german
state and the german constitution
and what they said was particularly
concerning
were sort of connections to right-wing
groups especially
far-right extremists like the
reichsberger for example
who questioned the validity of the
modern german state
anashar thank you very much for this
update
you